well i called the council the world
athletics council together today to
discuss the situation and to cut to the
chase
we have now excluded
our
authorized neutral athletes they're
russian athletes they've been given that
status
uh for uh many years and for obvious
reasons around anti-doping
and also the belarusian athletes we've
excluded them from our world
championship series this year
and for the foreseeable future so we
have five world championships in
different guises we have a in fact i'm
sitting talking to in oman on friday we
have the world race walk
championships
and so we had to move quickly to make
sure that we were able to convey
our
well just the appalling nature of what
we witnessed and
the issue for us now is that those
athletes will not be competing here or
in any of our world championships this
year
and this is a complete ban they're not
allowed to compete you know under a
neutral flag or with no national anthem
no russian flag a complete ban
yeah they will not be competing in any
of our world championship events and we
have five world championships this year
on four different continents but be very
clear about it um they will not be the
russian athletes will not be competing
under uh neutral status which they have
and the belarusian athletes will not be
competing either they are excluded
now i know and we've talked many times
about this that you are instinctively i
think against
um boycotts and sporting boycotts
because you think it
um you know hurts the athletes i mean
you competed in 1980 for instance what
is different about this what makes this
uh something that you think um deserves
an all-out ban
well mark first of all you're right it's
not my natural instinct i didn't come
into the sport and i certainly didn't
seek to become president of the sport to
sanction athletes and prevent them from
competing but
this is a very very different scale of
problem you know the russian athletes
have been banned in our sport and we've
been very tough with the only member
federation that chose to suspend the
russian federation because of it
egregious doping
uh an egregious doping record and
incursion into our own integrity
but look i've always fought hard for
maintaining the primacy of the athletes
and the independence of sport
but on this occasion i think we have to
recognize there is a global uh response
it's not that sport is
alone as it has in the past carried the
burden when other organizations
governments it's been business as usual
we have to recognize that we're part of
something far bigger and our own
interests at the moment have to be
secondary to
the
to you know the the united nature of
solidarity here uh it's a modest
contribution but we were very very clear
the council was very clear uh that this
was on a scale i mean the
appalling acts of barbarity that are
being witnessed every minute uh in under
you know in under this situation is
something that my sport and i know many
many other sports uh
can't just sit the dance out not on this
occasion
and i um heard someone trying to defend
you know continuing with russian
athletes and belarusian athletes
the other day but
as someone pointed out here to me
yesterday what about ukrainian athletes
these ukrainian athletes can't do
anything at the moment and a lot of the
ukrainian athletes are actually signing
up for a volunteer force to fight uh
president putin's army um have you been
horrified what's what's been happening
here
yes i have and mark you are you know
you're in the epicenter of it
um but i i none of us could sit here and
accept
uh russian athletes or belarusian
athletes competing while we have
ukrainian athletes some in bunkers some
not able to leave the country um it just
doesn't it felt entirely wrong and look
just a few hours literally an hour and a
half before my council meeting this
afternoon that uh sanctioned that
excluded those athletes i was you know
in a very interrupted facetime
conversation with a very senior figure
in ukrainian athletics who was you know
in a bunker protecting his family this
is unsustainable and we had to do
something and you know we've been as
tough as we possibly can and i think
other sports are
following uh in exactly the same way and
this has to be a global response this
can't just be borne by governments or
you know the united nations everybody
that is in a position to make their
feelings truly felt has has to be
articulate and clear about it
yeah and what about fifa and the ioc i
mean two organizations that
if i can say it put it this way not
quick to find their moral conscience
well look let's not go back into the
history of this sport has responded i
think in the right way
we were very clear
five years ago that the level of doping
that was taking place in russia was
unacceptable it was destroying the
fabric of our sport
we suspended the russian federation
we have a road map for reinstatement
that clearly is now seriously in
jeopardy
and we need to make sure that uh you
know the purpose and the values of our
sport shine through it's not always easy
sometimes decisions have to be made that
are unnecessarily pragmatic and you want
to always defend
the primacy and the independence of
sport but this goes way way beyond any
philosophical discussions
about athletes or even the the right of
a federation to exist
this is now uh so serious that sport has
to
not sit the dance it cannot sit the
dance out on this okay